köln morgens 7 uhr 30 unterwegs mit
ehrenamtlerin tanja schmiede hallo so
was steht denn jetzt an frau schmiede ok
fangen ins hotel dann fangen wir den
buchladen dann fahren wir spenden
einladen dann fangen wir die spenden
wieder ausladen dann fahren sie also ich
meine das nicht was für die ganze woche
ansteht was für heute steht das war
toll ich hatte mich auf einen
entspannten hilfreichen tag eingestellt
na gut als erstes fahren wir zu einer
firma die professionell spenden sammeln
jetzt wird ja mal angepackt sagt ja
meinen arm nehmen du kannst ja mal jagen
können sie vielleicht noch ein bisschen
foto für ins tor machen was ich später
machen
endlich ich bin in meinem helfer element
es tut gut der mama hälfte war das fühlt
sich direkt bruder anstellen auspacken
ja jeder handgriff sitzt jetzt kommt der
ehrenamtler in mir richtig durchgesetzt
auch nur das mikrofon mit leben und dann
kann es schon helfen einladen da ist
richtig wir könnten ein bisschen
schneller arbeiten mainz ist auch
schneller fertig da drin weil es also
ich wäre ja mit dem u bahn wenn ich
alleine gemacht hätte schon draußen
die firma inatura vermittelt sachspenden
aus ganz europa das meiste eigentlich in
deutschland wird vernichtet zumal es für
unternehmen immer noch billiger ist
dinge zu entsorgen statt zu spenden ist
wieso das hin ja weil sie müssen und
umsatzsteuer draufzahlen egal ob sie
geld dafür bekommen oder nicht es gibt
ein lösungsansatz ist auch im
koalitionsvertrag versprochen das zu tun
aber es hat sich noch nichts dann hab
ich dann gutes gefühl oder wir haben
jetzt auch einstigen kanzler
ja der war als finanzminister schon für
das thema zu stellen
und
kanzleramt ja aber es ist ja jetzt
mittag da würden sich an mittagspause
anbieten
wir haben bis jetzt keine zeit für
nächste station eine tafel in köln porz
überraschung bei der tafel wieder kisten
schleppen
ich brauche mein ehrenamt hat er sich
ein bisschen um mich kümmert faule
lebensmittel werden aussortiert aber
warum muss immer alles so schnell gehen
die faulen
die leute kommen gleich die leute kommen
gleich bis zu 800 menschen versorgt
diese station der tafel in der woche
wir kriegen die lebensmittel von der
tafel wir sind ein eingetragener verein
wir leben wir sind gemeinnützig wir
bekommen keinen cent für die entsorgung
der lebensmittel also wir bleiben noch
auf diesen kosten sitzen und die frage
ist doch wie kann das eigentlich sein
dass der staat sich aus solchen
geschichten so rauszieht
bei so viel engagement freut man sich
natürlich dass man eine goldene
ehrenamtskarte bekommt und die hat so
viele vorteile haben sie schon mal eine
führung durch die restmüll
verbrennungsanlage gemacht
ja aber das ist doch steht ihm noch zu
die führung durch die restmüll
verbrennungsanlagen das muss man eben
auch immer erklären auch der
ehrenamtskarte steht das drauf aber wir
haben eine kleine ehrenamtskarte nach
wahl weil es so ein blödsinn
ehrenamtler übernehmen rund um die uhr
aufgaben des staats und wollen dann
sicher mehr als eine goldene
plastikkarte ja das macht mich traurig
machen wir leben in einem der reichsten
länder der erde wir haben 100 milliarden
für offen wer wir wir finanzieren
irgendwelche gruseligen opern mit weiß
ich nicht und wir haben wir kriegen es
als als staat nicht auf die kette oder
als gesellschaft den leuten genug zu
essen zu gehen für heute sind die
lebensmittel verteilt zurück zu tanja
geschafft feierabend noch nicht wir
haben nochmals vor uns fünf termine ist
21 uhr aber ich hab was für dich
die hirne monat
ich kann umsonst in die restmüll
verbrennungsanlage
[Musik]
nein ich mache hier gar nichts mehr
bevor ihr nicht den kanal abonniert und
nike dallas
ich hab die schnauze voll
loslassen abo da